mark twain is credited with the
quotation golf is a good walk spoiled so
one can only imagine what he'd think of
the sports more modern incarnation speed
golf it is as it sounds a faster paced
version where golfers run the course in
between swings final scores are a
combination of speed in minutes and
shots the world's top ranked woman in
the sport is lauren cupp a mother of
three and golf coach she and her husband
also a world champion speed golfer on a
semi-private course in central new york
that's where we headed to get a feel for
what speedgolf is like and how on earth
cup got started with it
it gives the term grip it rip it a whole
new meaning
speed golf
i can get in 18 holes in under an hour
nine holes in just over 20 minutes
lawrence eats cup is the women's world
number one in the sport
so it's the sport of golf but it's
played at a more modern pace i like that
more modern pace or some would say a
crazier pace because you're running the
golf course it is a bit odd competitive
speed golf like the u.s tour cup is a
part of plays on traditional 18-hole
courses no carts or caddies each minute
on the course is equal to a stroke with
again the two tallied for a final score
the lower the better
take cups world record round from last
august a 122 which is a combined score
of one under par in 50 minutes
some of the best men in the world are
running an 18-hole course in 39 minutes
so it's really fast-paced is there a
comparison out there in the sports world
i think biathlon is pretty close there's
a lot of endurance involved but when
you're doing the short game you have to
lower your heart rate in order to make
that fine motor skills swing
cuff grew up playing traditional golf
just one of a handful of competitive
sports for her at hamilton college she
was on the track and field and
volleyball teams when she realized her
athletic passion was golf what was it
about golf that sort of hit something i
think maybe i saw the end was near for
team sports for me i don't know i just i
just found that that that was going to
give me this ability to play a lifelong
sport cup help launch the women's golf
team at hamilton college the same team
she currently coaches a couple more
minutes and we're going to switch along
with the men so come on over before
taking both over cupp competed in
amateur golf but says speedgolf was
never really in her sights how did you
find it i just stumbled upon it on
youtube so did you just come out to the
course and say okay now i'm gonna do it
that's exactly what i did that's exactly
what i did i took a few clubs in each
hand played nine holes was absolutely
exhausted after hated it while i was
doing it and then i was like i had to
try this again
and cup says the timing couldn't have
been better i had just had a baby i
became a new mom got a new job working
at the college and it was a beautiful
time but i really felt like i lost my
identity as an athlete during that time
you didn't have four hours to go right
right exactly right i didn't have time
to play five hours i didn't have time to
go to the range and practice for three
four hours like i used to but when i saw
speedgolf i said that might be something
i could get into if i could get in all
18 holes in an hour
that i could get my practice in and my
golf in once i found out that this was
being played competitively that there
was a u.s open that there was a world
championship that there were records to
be broken that's when i was like this
could be for me where i could still play
competitive golf
cup quickly transitioned from casual to
competitive speed golfer learning on the
fly so you do have to think about angles
and okay there's a bridge on this hole
so i want to hit my drive closer to the
bridge so that i don't have to go all
the way around
you are thinking certainly about the
shortest way to the hole
and sometimes cupp says you're not
thinking at all
you don't have time to take a practice
swing do the pre-shot routine you're not
deciding in between clubs and getting
exact yardages right it's a little more
of a feeling game
so are we getting in our own way when we
play regular golf balls basically it
does i think it shows you that all of
that pre-shot routine that overthinking
is just not necessary to golf or
possibly all those clubs
your bag tell me about what you are
carrying it's not the bags we see on the
tours exactly right i usually carry
five to six clubs depending on on the
course that we're playing okay i always
carry a driver a putter a wedge have to
have a wedge right right in the bunker
um two irons okay usually a six and a
nine if i'm playing a lengthy course
i'll also bring a five wood then there's
a matter of running
cup says she averages about a seven
minute mile but add in the stops for
swings it's closer to ten often times
instead of going over all the way to the
bridge you'll just jump right over the
creek
i get into a rhythm out there you know
for example i hit the shot i watch it
take off i've been down to pick up my
tea in the bag and by the time i have my
head up i can watch it land as i'm
running down the fairway then comes the
toughest part for cup
putting what's going through your mind i
mean we're walking it but as you're
getting up to the green sure so right
now i'm looking at the ball i'm looking
at the terrain of the green i'm also
thinking about getting my breathing
under control taking some nice deep
breaths so that i can set up and hit the
putt so you have to find some way to
putt with the bag
oh my god you putt with the bag you have
to yes otherwise it's too time consuming
to leave it off oh my god
i guess you get used to it yeah
how did you figure out oh go in come on
oh that was pretty good at least it's
close
[Laughter]
yeah sit and go
it's interesting you started doing this
because you were new mom
needed time you didn't have all the time
to get out there
mother to three now
yes you and your husband run the golf
course where we are
i don't even know how you have time for
speed golf even in that not much time
just enough for speed golf
that's the great thing about it and
that's what we do at night time in the
summer time is we flip flop so i watch
the kids he plays nine holes in 20
minutes when he comes in he takes his
shower by the time he's done showering
i'm done with nine holes and um and we
go to dinner
it's nice that we can do that and still
have family time yeah night time and the
kids will run with us
too
and it's that next generation that cup
says speedgolf may be tailor-made for
this is not let's get rid of
regular golf right this is just let's
add this on right let's play the game in
a different way
in a time-saving way i would hope that
this would appeal to golfers but also to
runners fitness enthusiasts to the
junior whose dad's been trying to get
him to play forever but it's too slow
and too time consuming that wants to
play quickly and that is used to playing
other sports it's not the hangout on the
golf course social golf that some people
may love right you can get to the 19th
hole a little faster though that's very
true and that is sometimes the best hole
of the day yes
that is a drinking joke that's what
happens at 19. so a couple things
remember this is the same yardage as a
normal course that she's playing she did
tell me when she's playing competitively
she'll play around leading up to that
tournament at a normal pace so you do
get a little bit of a feel for the
course and how it's going to play but it
does take that mental aspect out of it
it translates to tv sort of maybe i can
say this to you that piece ran 702 she's
averaging about a seven minute mile as
she runs what so think about it in the
time of that piece is how long yeah
that's incredible but obviously as a cup
has this amazing endurance and
enthusiasm you've got to be good in the
first place to do any good at sprinkles
and this is she told me she will play a
regular round in the same uh the same
will shoot the same as she does in a
speed golf round you have to have the
golf skill obviously in order to do it
but she even said you could speed walk
it if you don't want to run it and
you're playing not competitively so give
it a try that's very awesome very
awesome stuff i want to do it motherhood
sure makes you more efficient that is
exactly